sexy
à voir
on attend
[Musique]
les bateaux pneumatiques rouge des
secouristes vont partout surtout là où
les bateaux traditionnels ne
s'aventurent pas là on est dans la veine
dans la zenn on parle de courant et vous
allez voir en aval de la pilot pour ya
ce qu'on appelle des contre courants et
on profite de ça justement ces deux
d'utiliser la loire à son avantage la
fia quelqu'un de l'autre on peut
balancer un boot attention avec leur
poids plumes et leurs moteurs
surpuissants il passe de la mer à la
loire prêts à intervenir en cas de
danger malgré le courant les embâcles et
les compteurs comme c'est des petits
bateaux compte pas forcément un gros
tirant d'eau aussi c'est un sujet
intéressant ça permet d'approcher au
plus près il ya deux ans sous le pont
tina est un bateau qui s'était échoué
sur les rochers donc on a pu arriver et
dégager les personnes à bord du bateau
avant de traiter que le bateau ça reste
toujours les personnes d'abord le
matériel ensuite pour les huit
sauveteurs nautiques le festival de
loire c'est l'occasion de s'entraîner et
de se former avec ses bateaux ça fait
deux ans que j'ai c'est le deuxième
festival de l'or que je fais franchement
c'est plutôt à des poteaux vraiment cool
en fait et on apprend énormément de
choses en fils et là on s'en va
ils sont petits long
ils sont rapides c'est un peu m et
gascogne quand on veut quand on en a
besoin
des heures de navigation sur valoir
durant le festival qui préparent aussi
leur intervention en cas d'inondation
comme en 2015
[Musique]